- Here's how it's gonna work.
Joel and I have identical
grocery items and bag options.
We have 40 seconds to bag everything
as quickly and carefully as possible.
Once time is up, Grace will
judge our bagging abilities
and declare a winner.
Do you get it?
- Can you repeat the rules?
- No, no.
I'm not using that, keep it.
But wait, we need a prize.
We need a prize.
- This could be for the cash.
- So any ideas for a prize?
- If Joel wins, all the men
in the audience gets my book.
- Okay, okay, okay, okay
For free? Free ninety-Five?
For free.
- Those four dudes are excited.
(laughing)
- If Kelly wins, all the
women will get the book.
- See
(applause)
- Wow
Okay
Here we go.
- Stoked!
Okay Grace, start us off.
- All right here we go.
(audience cheering) Kelly, Kelly, Kelly!
- What the? Joel, Joel.
- Three, two, one
- A fan has got you!
Go!
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
(Joel)- Done, done, done.
Done, done.
- I like how you put the eggs on top.
(laughing)
- Done
(screams)
- Oh my God, you're so
invited for game night.
I love your spirit.
- I'm sorry I ruined
it, ruined, all right.
Okay.
- I'm so strong
All right.
- Okay
- Okay, judge away. Judge
- Okay so we're doing points.
(angelic singing)
- Kelly and Joel both get a point because
they used brown paper bags.
- Yes
We're saving the environment.
Yes.
- Okay.
- But we should have used reusable, right?
- Should of, you would
have gotten more points
for reusable.
- Here's why I didn't.
Because you are getting more.
Look this is bigger, this is why.
I'm not gonna get as much in here,
I'm just saying.
- I'm on your side on this one.
Yeah.
(laughing)
I see the mistake, but okay.
- Kelly gets two points
for the eggs on top.
(audience cheering)
- That's what I'm saying,
that's what I'm saying.
- Joel gets two points
for the bread on top.
- Okay okay
(audience cheering)
- These are-
- Super heavy, they're frozen
- No, they're lighter
- They're lighter than
the liter of milk
- and the chips?
- Okay, minus one point for Kelly
- Damn!
- Yes!
- Because they are heavy and frozen.
One extra point for Joel
- Oh God
Yeah
- Teacher's pet
- These are crushable.
- Honestly, I was just worried about
saving the Oreos.
(audience laughing)
- Five points for Kelly
for even distribution
of weight.
- Even distribution! I thought about it,
I thought about it.
(audience cheering)
That's right, that's right.
- So, it's okay to crush things
- No, no, no minus one point for Joel
because the eggs were not on top.
- The bread and the chips
were on top of the eggs
- And this should have been in the middle
cushioned.
- Okay
- Minus a point for Kelly
for these on the bottom
- No, they were on the side,
they were on the side.
Maybe like a .5, like a,
- Only one point minus.
The Oreos are good, extra two points.
- On the bottom, the
Oreos were on the bottom.
(audience cheering)
- The Oreos worth its rate.
- Everything heavy is on the bottom.
- I'm gonna celebrate my win.
- A final addition of five points for Joel
because he put all of
the cold stuff together
and even distribution.
So eight to eight
- I'm good with that.
So if everybody wins, then
everybody gets a book!
- Yes!!!
- That's great and just whoever wants it,
just grab one of the
guitars hanging on the wall.
Just grab it, go ahead, just have at it.
Whatever you like.
- Good job ý'all. Great job.
- That's fine.